c'est un plaisir de les retrouver nos
panélistes de nos vendredi électoraux je
les salue michael fortier françoise
boivin gilles duceppe et brian gallant
bonsoir à vous bonsoir alors c c'était
ce fut la cinquième et dernière campagne
semaine de cette campagne électorale on
en est au jour 34 énormément de choses à
dire un peu plus tard va falloir qu'on
vienne avec vous sur votre bilan de
campagne beaucoup de choses à dire à ce
chapitre est également et on va vous
demander de sortir votre boule de
cristal mais d'abord cette cinquième
semaine j'ai presque vous entendre et
qu'est ce qui a retenu votre attention
gilles duceppe moi je passe ses étés la
poursuite du débat sur le débat en
anglais
on a vu même notre armée nationale bah
oui c'est par là le service national
motion unanime les chefs des partis
fédéralistes ont fini par s'excuser en
france une semaine après il aurait pu le
faire en anglais dans leur point de
presse ce soir même mais ils ont senti
que ça animait le débat au québec on a
vu une remontée du bloc conséquemment à
cela donc pas pour rien qu'ils sont
excusés et ils l'ont fait au québec donc
on a parlé de ça encore le toute la
semaine portail avait d'autres enjeux
mais celui-là april est la plus
importante des places je crois est ce
qui vous concerne réconforter mais deux
choses oui j'ai là j'ai le prépare aussi
le nombre de canadiens qui ont voté par
anticipation c'est quand même un nom et
pression' ans le fait qu'ils aient près
de six millions de personnes qui est
voté on peut pas déduire quoi que ce
soit de ce vote hâtif mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que ces gens leurs produits tout
était plus en sait par quoi que ce soit
que s'est passé cette semaine surtout
l'appel qu'ont fait les deux grands
partis à d'anciens premiers ministres
monsieur chrétien monsieur moroni deux
tentatives selon - qui sentait un peu
[Musique]
des manoeuvres de dernière minute puis
demande le sucre et is c'est pas un
hasard pour les retrouver en ontario
pense pas qu'on l'aurait vu
nécessairement au québec dit me giroux
les sponsors pour le présenter au québec
parce que je pense qu'à l'extérieur du
québec il n'a pas le même attrait qu'au
québec mais pour moi on voit les deux
grands partis qu'ils cherchaient
à catalyser sur ces deux grands hommes
politiques et à essayer de mobiliser
leurs bases parce qu'il sent très bien
que la joute extrêmement ces gens
tendaient chantal hébert dire que ces ex
leader sur ce n'est pas pour inciter les
gens voter pour tel ou tel parti mais
pour mobiliser les troupes comme tel sur
le terrain la proche du vote pour faire
sortir la famille vote comme on dit
souvent comme le dit s'il ya quelque
chose que chantal hébert sait ce qu il
me dit
ça vous honore
j'en suis honoré alexis bombe est tombée
et a pu vous le voyez ainsi repensé avec
vous françoise qu'est-ce qui est ce qui
ce qui a attiré davantage votre votre
attention au delà de ce que mes deux
collègues ont dit ils ont raison par
rapport au débat anglais qui s'est
continuée un petit peu mais qui a
plafonné je pense vers le milieu de la
semaine et on sait que monsieur monsieur
blanchet se cherche quelque chose à
faire lundi si le restant de la campagne
fait qu' on va espérer de faire de son
côté de faire sortir les voteurs le dis
moi ce sera la sortie de jason kenny en
dernière semaine de campagne alors qu'on
a passé toute la campagne presque cinq
semaines à se dire nous sommes des world
et jason kenney de le voir sortir de
façon aussi dramatique avec la situation
en alberta 100 euros peut-être pas
d'impact alexis je peux dire que ça va
changer toute la donne en alberta mais
certainement que le reste du canada le
québec inclus regarde d'où sort et ça
ramène à l'avant scène ce que monsieur
trudeau voulais vraiment voir c'est à
dire une campagne électorale sur la
pandémie et cela ramène à l'avant scène
à lens ça peut avoir un impact et aussi
les chiffres sortis par élections canada
officiellement mercredi sur le nombre de
personnes au canada qui ont demandé des
voix de pouvoir voter par la poste
sachant fort bien qu'il ne seront cotées
le camp ils sont dus de la
circonscription même que le lendemain
mercredi est sûre ça pourrait avoir un
impact quand on regarde certaines
circonscriptions où la marge entre le
gagnant ou la gagnante est la deuxième
place est tellement mince que plus de
vote par la poste qui vont entrer alors
rejoint de voir comment tout ça va
s'inscrire dans la soirée électorale
donc se disent dévoilé important de la
semaine pas tout à fait sûr surtout
paraît-il en colombie britannique où le
vote comme ça par la poste était
particulièrement populaire blanc quant à
vous à vous de réagir maintenant cette
cinquième semaine de campagne
mes collègues choisi je pense les marins
qui avaient à souligner alors peut-être
juste ajouter des commentaires
c'est que mon ami et chrétiens en
sortent et khumalo même temps j'ai
trouvé ça c'est assez drôle même est
intéressant mais et à participation vous
venez de faire un très bon point les
petits y est je me demande qu'est ce que
ça veut dire l'ampleur du britannique
contraint sidérant que le npd lors des
élections provinciales qui a eu lieu
lors de la pandémie a vraiment misé sur
le vote par le poste alors je me demande
si une indication que limpide et la
machine
pour une bd à la colombie-britannique a
vraiment misé sur cette opportunité mais
si j'étais à choisir entre les trois je
vais dire la situation en alberta avec
françoise c'est vraiment
malheureux tour premièrement son message
du jour ça fait dur rires
c'est vraiment un moment difficile pour
lui qu'il est un peu le moteur il ya
tout part du ca cette semaine mais c'est
vraiment aussi un cadeau pour les
libéraux ah ils sont capable maintenant
de parler de pandémie est vraiment avec
la compagne que le parti a eu de
profondes minable évidemment s'ils
peuvent avoir les gens pensaient la
pandémie et comment qui veulent en
sortir la fin du billet c'est qu'ils
demeurent au petit pouvait les mener
mais ils venaient de pays à travers la
pandémie
dans la comparaison
et voici le résultat
je dis pas que c'est tous les canadiens
3 d'influencé en sommet dans une
élection serrée s'il ya une pourcentage
ça peut faire et me suis cogné encore
aujourd'hui qui insistait pour présenter
sa comme étant un référendum sur justin
trudeau cette élection aussi mais voilà
qu'avec la sphère haqqani l'albertain
tout le reste la brouille un peu
peut-être le message où ça va jouer
cette élection là selon vous ils sont
tous soit 3 en grande partie en ontario
aujourd'hui j'ai duceppe au québec et
ailleurs ça joue mais je pense ça joue
un peu partout en ontario c'est très
serré et c'est évident que les libéraux
vont dire que le vote progressiste doit
aller chez eux afin de ne pas faire
passer les conservateurs monsieur singh
voisine en eau sont les deux sont
pareils d'encre c'est chez nous c'était
des ddd des marges très minimes entre
ces trois parties la même chose en
colombie britannique
maintenant l'alberta effectivement nuire
énormément conservateurs non seulement
en raison des cinq années mais aussi
maxime bernier qui va chercher tous ceux
et celles qui sont contre la vaccination
il gagnera pas mais il peut enlever des
votes importants conservateur et et
faire en sorte que peut-être le npd qui
populaire un adapteur au provincial et
monsieur kenny qui est très impopulaire
quant au québec il y a le bloc a en
moyenne et je regardais les sondage de
léger léger on était d'accord sur ce
système bi poin avant chez les
francophones et ça c'est important il ya
un certain nombre de comtés ou qui sont
très serrés or c'est sur ces comptes et
que fait monsieur blanchet va tenter de
stabiliser le voc et faire en sorte de
maintenir l'orée de leur donner résultat
sinon avoir un peu plus que la dernière
fois donc la bataille va être importante
aussi mais je pense qu'il va avoir
beaucoup plus d'énergie porter en
ontario et en colombie britannique en
raison du vote du npd qui n'arrête pas
les libéraux mais monsieur otto là pour
profiter de ça et l'alberta les lui a
nui énormément monsieur o'toole qui elle
passe tout le reste de la campagne et
trois petits jours qui restent en
ontario michael fortier dans le choses à
dire on vient d'évoquer maxime bernier
le fait que ça pourrait dans certains
endroits faire la différence comment
résumer ce qui s'est passé que monsieur
autour le doute déçus d'abord par sa
performance nous non au dessus tout
puisse pas une question partisane post
ou et je pense que objectivement mes
collègues aussi directe essence rapporte
aujourd'hui lancement on était au
cinoche pense pas que brian était là
mais je pense que les attentes de mes
collègues et même les miennes pour être
honnête par rapport à renault tour moi
j'avais des attentes nettement basse
donc au tour le promener une mauvaise
campagne le son fait un diagnostic de ce
qui s'est passé les contours c'est ce
que prévu que des bons coups d'iraty
mais je pense que c'est vrai pour tous
les chefs de si vous posez la question
avec l'alberta c'est sûr c'est certain a
été préférable pour lui que l'alberta
gère un peu mieux la situation que vit
et que lui-même traîne un peu ses
distances
de la gestion de l'alberta alors il
faudra qu'ils vivent avec ça pour
répondre à la question que vous posez
c'est à dire ça se joue voyons quelles
régions sont importants je pense à vous
demandiez l'exacte réalité c'est toutes
les régions où wade porte environ regard
des libéraux dans les maritimes prime
vous établi qu'ils verront perdre 6 est
compté l'ania pearl 3,4 au québec il ya
1 8 9 10 à l'ontario de ça peut débouler
v et là on va tous restés de bourg
jusqu'à minuit 1h du matin et est même
comme le disait françoise jusque là mais
où le surnom mais pour les votes qui
vont entrer par la poste donc je pense
pas qu'il ya une seule région mais
d'être l'ontario et polo britannique hms
apparaissent particulièrement important
pour les deux grands partis c'est un peu
ça qui explique peut-être la journée
d'un job médecine françoise boivin
aujourd'hui sherbrooke halifax à se
termine à l'autre bout du pays dans
l'ouest comme quoi comme dim comme dit
l'oms et macau voilà c'est tout tout
l'étoupé région sont importantes toutes
les régions sont importantes je pense
qu'on dit depuis le début que ça va se
jouer essentiellement dans le sud de
l'ontario le 9,05 la
colombie-britannique où en passant ce
même pas une bataille à trois c'est une
bataille à deux entre les conservateurs
et les néo et les néo-démocrates
l'atlantique où on verra rapidement
on va le sentir ce qui se passe si les
conservateurs vont bouger ces quelques
sièges dont parlait maiko ça peut être
lourd de conséquences pour ce qui s'en
vient on l'avait vu en 2015 que ça
passait par l'atlantique puis ça ce
constat ce continué par tous pour la
vague trudeau on verra s'ils ont un
effet anti trudeau à cette élection
aussi si c'est vraiment un référendum
sur sa personne sinon ça va être des
batailles rangées
réellement faire sortir le vote le taux
participation alexis va avoir une grande
influence et aussi parce qu'on a
peut-être vu un beau taux de
participation pour le vote par
anticipation
mais je suis pas convaincu qu'on va voir
la même chose le dis pour le reste il la
colombie britannique il ya beaucoup de
sièges aller chercher pour les niveaux
des mots que le nouveau parti
démocratique et les conservateurs qui
veulent pas perdre leurs acquis le nom
au plus mais c'est vrai qu'en 2015 dans
l'atlantique brendan avait donné le ton
c'est une histoire en 2019 qu'est ce
qu'on doit y voir cette fois ci
c'est évident que la garantie qu'elle va
envoyer des messages
avec ce gars
avancée des sièges ici les sondages
démontrent si sa pente celle ci les
sondages portent jusqu'à la journée
d'élection est un gain de quatre sièges
les conservateurs
cela dit la fin de la journée le québec
l'ontario la colombie-britannique s'est
lassé les promesses qui ont du 6 juillet
lorsqu'on lit d'aller dans des jours
d'une campagne comme celui ci que très
serré les chefs se sait où va falloir
est vraiment pour autour ça fait dix ans
que sinon ontario pour le meeting à son
père pense l'ontario fait dix ans et
pour les libéraux si triaud je dirais
fin de la journée il ya vraiment des
courses à tous aux personnes à toi un
trop petit il y évidemment le
pcpc le parti un damier en jean pull à
l'appui des consommateurs en plus alors
vraiment ça peut être un cas où il ya
plusieurs saisons dario qui se trouve
être un pour cent pour la partie et en
effet ça ça se fait décidément jusqu'à
que voir alors je pense que les chefs ça
n'importe quelle élection
beaucoup si l'ontario maintenant une
élection ça allait comme celui-ci où on
peut avoir vraiment des progressistes
qui se divisent on peut revoir peut-être
doigts qui se vit ici vont bien sûr
concentrer sur l'ontario bon maintenant
c'est le dernier droit de la campagne
mais c'est aussi le dernier droit de ce
panel on voit cydia les rendements pour
elle la dernière question à deux volets
que je vous posais le point tournant de
la campagne et votre boule de cristal à
quoi s'attendre j'ai dû simple mais tu
vois tourneur c'était le point de départ
en disant pourquoi l'élection tout le
monde disait ça va durer deux jours et
on n'a pas d'accord cette semaine
les prédictions je vais contredire mon
mentor yogi berra qui disait je ne fais
jamais de prédiction surtout celles qui
concernent l'avenir
moi je pense que on aimerait
gouvernement libéral minoritaire donc
monsieur trudeau a perdu son pari
appuyé par le npd ni eau ni l'eau de ces
partis ne vous dois aller rapidement aux
élections parce que dans les jeunes sera
encore plus mécontent le blog fera un
peu mieux je pense que la dernière fois
les conservateurs
sur demeurons deuxième partie opposition
officielle va sans dire m ça pose la
question monsieur legault aura deux
parti centralisateur au pouvoir il va
être pris dans un dilemme comme celui où
était vrai robert bourassa 90 il
s'entendait bien que ma journée mais
avait beaucoup de difficulté que le
reste du canada que fera t-il ouais on
verra monsieur bourassa qu'il a
paraphrasé quoi qu'on dise quoi qu'on
fasse michael fortier aussi la même
question devenait part je pense que les
prix y est tellement d'événements leur
ont demandé de west on prend du coup je
vous dirais alexis je vous dirais les
débats pas nécessairement parce qu'il ya
eu des des coûts de wade chaos la
fameuse question quand on est opposé à
ce projet cela oui seulement et où je
dirais aussi que le débat dans les deux
débats français nous ont présenté un
trudeau et on tourne pas autour c'est là
vraiment qui s'est présenté à
l'auditoire francophones et monsieur
trudeau je vous l'avais dit dans
d'autres grandes et vous le vendredi
surtout droit bien fait de lancer dans
ces débats et surtout faut se rappeler
où des bons français du trou d'eau était
dans une pente
pantelante mais une compte néanmoins et
il a stoppé l'hémorragie et en stoppant
l'hémorragie c'est là qu'on a senti à la
fois sa cote remonter et celle de vue
autour pas nécessairement pc mais
plafonné et de remonter ouais moi
c'était des éléments très importants
parce que à partir de ce débat ne s'est
passé plein d'autres trucs sur la
question des prédictions des céans
nettement chez que vous souhaiteriez
cournon je souhaiterais en particulier
mais
c'est quand vos attentes ça peut être
aussi escale à lisbonne games ont
clairement à geely la trans'oise qui ont
déjà dit que cette élection n'était pas
nécessaire
moi au contraire je pense que les cinq
dernières semaines avec le nombre de
sujets qui ont été évoqués et la façon
dont on veut gérer le canada dans l'ère
post pandémie moi je pense que cette
élection là aura été très utile devant
le gouvernement qui est encore
minoritaire ce qui va être le corps mais
je parle pas ici de l'exercice inutile
parce qu'on a une élection qui aura pas
donné un gouvernement majoritaire dit
pas sur la démo avant françois
rapidement ben sait jamais si jamais
antidémocratique d'avoir une élection je
pense que personne sur ce panel qui
pense cependant entre les rêves et la
réalité des fois ya tout un monde alors
ce qui aurait été mon élément
déterminant pour moi dans cette campagne
c'était non seulement le départ l'un
d'eux justin trudeau et de la campagne
libérale sa puritaine je pense qu'ils
ont dû perdre au moins deux semaines
deux semaines et demie de la campagne
avant qu'on sache exactement quelle
importance réelle avait sept cette
campagne de fait d'avoir vu un erin
o'toole dans un aura un petit peu plus
positif de le connaître un peu mieux
aura été bon définitivement que le débat
anglais au revoir été un élément
déterminant les prédictions je les ai
faits aux mordus change pas une virgule
alors 141 pour les libéraux gouvernement
minoritaire a faibli ce qui mettra un
peu m dos dans le trouble avec son
caucus par après qui s'attendaient à une
majorité c'est comme ça qu'on l'avait
vendu pour comprendre encore pas
pourquoi il y en a pas plus parler comme
s'ils étaient gênées de ça mélanie joly
a corrigé le tir hier à infoman en
disant qu'ils voulaient avoir les deux
mains sur le voilà bravo pour la candeur
des fois on aime s'entendait vraies
réponses et 131 pour les conservateurs
38 pour le blog qu'il faut faire à
quelques gains et les néo-démocrates
aussi je pense j'avais du 27 et un verre
on n'a pas parlé de saint verny parce
que je le vois pas se faire élire même
si ça va être serré alors voilà on ne
peut pas plus précis que savent ouvrir
et d'en face non
c'est pas ça du tout l'idée mais quand
même au passage que s'intéresse en effet
à la scène précis à la barre et rod
bryden
d'accord presque tous les analyses qu'on
vient d'entendre mes collègues a
déjà dimensionnée et je pense que pour
plusieurs raisons de malwares trudeau a
pu démontrer qu'en par notation il y en
a déjà
il a aussi également eu l'occasion de
mettre en lumière son plein des qualités
qui sont plus adroits un des
consommateurs au moins autant d'options
et cela je pense à lui indien pu à
stabiliser dans les sondages de plus
faiblement de divorce avait indiqué plus
tôt pour quelques jours ça va vraiment
faire en sorte que tous les
consommateurs comme perdus les sites
médias était la question du québec en
anglais aussi évidemment c'était un
point tournant puis je pense que nous
allons analyser la campagne bien sûr
dans les semaines à venir ça pourrait
regagner un peu à faire une remontée et
je pense que si je t'ai pour faire des
prédictions je suis d'accord avec ce
crédit
je ferai juste un commentaire que c'est
ça les autres chronos minoritaires et si
on garde lors des dernières décennies sa
vie fréquemment et ça nous fait
questionner peut lorgner les premières
pénalisées je pense ici au canada aux
différentes aspects qui l'opinion mais
ça va être une bonne chose ça peut être
une bonne chose mais j'en ai aussi
c'est si honni pour chaque fois qu'il ya
des élections qui est déclenchée en un
produit vous comprenez direction
je suis un peu comme michael je pense
finalement sujets importants qui ont été
abordés et comme françoise hardy garde
entre autres un exercice démocratique
il peut avoir des choses qui sortent ça
m'a
tuer de voix pour bien expliquer au
début de la campagne pourquoi qui a
déclenché cette élection notre dernier
mot comme toujours ce sera aux électeurs
et s'approche dans trois jours pour la
suite on verra bien combien ça va
prendre de temps avant qu'on ait le
résultat définitif mais ça c'est une
autre histoire en ce qui nous concerne
je prends quelques secondes pour vous
remercier toutes ses participations
semaine après semaine dans ce panel vous
avez enrichi vraiment de façon
importante nos réflexions face à ce
scrutin merci beaucoup cher panélistes
pouvoir